Nathan Fillion isn't just playing to be
the next Green Lantern he's also
planning to bring a fan of favorite back
could we be seeing Captain Reynolds fly
once more
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so we know we are getting season six of
the rookie and the actual Creator had to
go on Twitter yesterday and reassure
fans that Nathan Fillion's new plans to
become the Green Lantern or a version of
the Green Lantern in Guy Gardner for the
new DC Universe won't actually delay the
series Alexi Hawley was asked will
Nathan filling in be in Guy Gardner
delay the series delay the return of the
rookie and he said nope
but if you remember in your regular side
tracker you'll know that I did a video a
few months ago and I was talking about
how actually Nathan Fillion might not be
in season six of the rookie or at least
not as much as we've become used to now
one of his complaints at the end of the
um long Castle Run was actually doing 20
plus episodes a year is exhausting it
takes seven eight months of the year up
it requires 10 plus hour days and for a
show like castle where he's the main
character and even if he actually
doesn't have lines in a scene he still
appears in almost every single one
it was completely exhausting and
actually battered his health he said in
lots of ways he much prefers the rookie
because there's a much wider cast
the pressures on him are not quite as
severe now there is some rumor to
suggest that actually some filming for
season six has already started it's not
100 clear but we have seen some behind
the scenes stuff somehow behind the
scenes videos from some cast members
which does suggest it and Nathan Fillion
does appear in them I do not for a
second believe that he will just leave
the rookie to show his executive
producer of and a show that he actually
really does love but speaking to a
source of mind that has actually spoken
to representatives of Nathan Fillion it
does seem that his Camp believes that
the show is called the rookie and after
six years Nathan Fillion's character
isn't really a rookie anymore he's gone
on to become a fully fledged member of
LAPD and that maybe the show should
focus more on the newer younger actors
coming through the rookies
and that actually he does want to take a
big step back that he will still appear
in the show but it'll be in a far
smaller part this will allow him to go
over to the DC and do his Green Lantern
roles now we know that James Gunn is a
big fan of Nathan Philly and they are
good good friends Nathan Fillion
appeared in Guardians of Galaxy 3 he
also appeared in Suicide Squad he's also
said though that the Green Lanterns and
potentially Guy Gardner a very important
part of the upcoming DC Universe we know
from the comic books that boost of gold
a TV series that we know is coming as
part of the new DC lineup and Guy
Gardner were actually very important to
each other the guy Gardner was always
sort of Hal Jordan's number two at very
least in the early parts of the comics
that actually Guy Gardner was sort of
Hal Jordan's backup Green Lantern kind
of and the Booster Gold was actually
really important in making that happen
so will Guy Gardner actually be an
important part of the Booster Gold TV
series
very possible and as I've said James
Gunn has talked about how the Green
Lanterns are going to be very very
important in the new DC Universe by
having Guy Gardner in the very first
movie
of this new universe in Superman Legacy
we're actually seeing a younger Superman
it does seem that actually he's going to
follow through with that promise and
that the Green Lanterns really are going
to be core to a lot of the new
storylines does this mean that is going
to take up Nathan Fillion's time now I
actually did say to you in the video a
couple of months ago that Nathan Fillion
was planning a couple of movie roles now
we didn't know what that meant at the
time but my source is saying he tried to
Hint it was DC to me but couldn't really
say anything but now he's saying this is
what I was talking about that guy
Gardner is actually going to be a
relatively big role within the DC Nathan
Fillion has only had really cameos up
till now in the James Gunn movies but it
does look like that's going to change
but is this stepping back from the
rookie just about the DC or is there a
bigger idea as well from Nathan Fillion
well as I talked to you in the other
video about how he really really wants
to to come back with the Firefly he
really wants to be Malcolm Reynolds
again it's one of his favorite parts and
he would love to explore it further
talking to sources in and around his
Camp it does seem that Nathan Fillion is
very very keen to do this but he's never
really been able to figure out how now
Disney for a few years have been trying
to figure out how to bring the Firefly
back they've talked to virtually every
executive producer that has anything to
do with Disney and they've been
desperately trying to figure out how to
bring it back without annoying the
Firefly fans us brown coats are a little
bit obsessive about our Firefly we only
got a handful of episodes and we watched
them religiously I've watched them twice
this year already and probably after
doing this video I'm going to watch it
again
so brown coats will only accept the
Firefly if it is bloody brilliant and to
be fair and to Disney's credit they know
this it has to be amazing or we will
roundly dismiss it immediately they've
always said that the only real way to
bring the firefighter back is if Nathan
Fillion returns so look now Nathan
feeling for the rookie does kind of work
for Disney you know so
could that be his route back into the
Firefly well according to my sources no
because Nathan Fillion doesn't really
want to bring back a serious he's hoping
to bring back a couple of basically TV
movies and Disney don't own the movie
rights to the Firefly
Universal this and Universal has a very
good working relationship with Warner
Brothers
and guess who Warner Brother owns the DC
so as part of this deal with James Gunn
I'm being told that Nathan filling has
been talking to Warner Brothers about
having a partnership with universal that
he would absolutely love to bring back
the Firefly in a couple of TV movies
this would also mean the return of Joss
Whedon who Nathan Fillion is absolutely
determined to get involved he says
basically right Firefly without Nathan
Fillion isn't firefi but Firefly without
Joss Whedon isn't Firefly either
and this actually could be an
opportunity for Joss Whedon to get the
Redemption he arguably deserves
or doesn't yeah what would Universal do
this
well Nathan Fillion is just consistently
a very popular actor but also the
Firefly series is consistently voted one
of the most influential and most popular
Sci-Fi series ever made
in a vote a couple of months ago where I
felt I didn't actually agree with but
there was over six million votes on this
poll and actually five five came in at
number one it beat out Star Trek Star
Wars Battlestar Galactica everything to
be voted the most popular Sci-Fi series
ever made now I actually did a video on
that at the time I didn't agree with it
I would have put it in my top five I
wouldn't have made it number one there
just wasn't enough episodes for it to
really you know
to Warrant that title to Warrant that
Crown don't get me wrong if they'd have
had three or four seasons of it I
probably would have if they'd have
carried on being that brilliant but
after 14 episodes you can't really say
it's the best sci-fi show ever made
but the fact that it keeps appearing on
polls like this
is not going unnoticed as I say Disney
would love to bring this back
but Nathan Fillion is interested in
doing it with universal
and at the end of the day whatever
Nathan Fillion does will be Firefly
but guys I'd love for you to get to the
comments and tell me what you think this
idea about doing a couple of firefly TV
movies do you love it and do you
actually think that he's thinking about
why he may step back from the rookie
kind of makes sense now all of this is
very firmly in the rumor category at the
moment these are conversations that I
know have happened but at the moment
there are only conversations but the
fact that Nathan Fillion is going to
potentially have a very big role in the
DC really does mean it's going to be
very difficult for him to have a big
role in The Rookie and it does seem and
that we know from lots of interviews
Nathan Fillion is really ready to do
something a bit different with his
career so let's see what happens in the
next few months none of this will
probably be announced until after the
strikes but the strikes actually do give
Nathan Fillion Universal Warner Brothers
an opportunity to have the conversations
and that's really fascinating I'd love
to know what you think about those
possibilities though so get in the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like And subscribe and don't
forget to hit the Bell notification so
you never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the adverts you even get a
free gift after three months
so please go and check it out as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
foreign
[Music]